je voudrais tout d'abord vous faire
partager une conviction de femmes je
m'excuse de le faire devant cette
assemblée presque exclusivement composée
d'hommes
aucune femme ne recourt de gaieté de
coeur à l'avortement il suffit d'écouter
les femmes c'est toujours un drame cela
restera toujours un drame
c'est pourquoi si le projet qui vous est
présenté tient compte de la situation de
fait existantes s'il admet la
possibilité d'une interruption de
grossesse
c'est pour la contrôler et autant que
possible en dissuader la femme parmi
ceux qui combattent aujourd'hui une
éventuelle modification de la loi
répressive
combien sont ils ceux qui se sont
préoccupés d'aider ces femmes dans leur
détresse
combien sont ils ceux qui au delà de ce
qu'ils jugent comme une faute ont su
manifester aux jeunes mères célibataires
la compréhension et l'appui moral quand
elle avait un si grand besoin
[Applaudissements]